in the nfl's race of keeping up with the
joneses literally here's the sofi
stadium oculus board double-sided
one-of-a-kind high-resolution 4k video
seen by everyone in the stadium they
have
raised that baby from the rafters and it
will be ready to go when the stadium
opens and yesterday afternoon the rams
announced that the stadium will open on
august 14 preseason game against the
saints they're selling tickets for their
pre-season home games refunds will be
available if fans ultimately can't
attend or if the games are canceled but
the rams
putting the tickets on sale announcing
the dates and the rams you know we talk
all the time about in-season travel
chris
the rams have a great deal here they
have three of their games in the
preseason played at their home stadium
because one of the games is at the
chargers and then their last preseason
game is a very long arduous trip to las
vegas they hardly travel at all in the
month of august and that's a that's a
nice way to bank some some uh travel
time for later in the season if you're
not running all over the place in the
month of august as you're playing the
preseason games no that's i mean that's
that's like it really is a big gift to
players that time of the year when
you're worn out from training camp and
you haven't seen your family a lot to
take away some of that travel time to
have a little extra time at home or rest
your body or whatever it is i mean it's
great for the whole organization the
coaches included everybody catch your
breath that way uh it's very smart by
the rams to make sure you know they
don't have to go far from home that way
but i'm mike i don't know i don't you
know
maybe that the dallas stadium but i i'm
about as excited to see this rams in
vegas stadium this year as i am any
stadium that i can ever remember being
unveiled i mean they just have an
unbelievable futuristic type look i mean
i'm expecting them to some at some point
lift off the ground and fly into outer
space i mean that's how cool they look
so
i can imagine what it's going to look
like with all these people in it
or it's going to be the scene from close
encounters where they're going
synthesizing music back and forth right
until until the giant alien comes out we
got to take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports